we've got more breezes coming today a
few neighborhoods have been on the
breezy side this morning but not too
rough and we don't expect these to be
rough winds today just picking up a
little speed as we get through the day a
beautiful shot looking across the city
this morning temperatures across the
valley pretty much 70's valley wide
still a little warm in green valley at
80. 73 mountains edge seven hills we've
got 74 sunrise mountain mid 70s for
nellis and downtown a little cooler up
at aliante at 70. same for summerlin 71
at the lakes and already we've got some
northeasterly breezes at times out at
red rock 56 up there at kyle canyon
we've been in the upper 60s out in trump
and just under 70 degrees up in mesquite
this morning 98 for the high is what
we're looking for that's right about
where we were the last two days at 99
have not hit 100 degrees yet not yet but
it's very possible we will before the
weekend 102 is the record high for today
so we're awfully close to that sunset at
7 42
this evening here are your headlines
breezy today stronger winds thursday
friday that will pick up the fire
weather danger again for us too because
we're staying very dry temps 95 to 100
degrees so above normal until we get to
the end of the week these stronger winds
are with a cooler system that will move
through and that will open the door for
a bit of a break in these extra warm
temperatures before the weekend so
here's a cold front today it's a very
weak one though it's not going to have
much of an effect on our temperatures
for the next few days fire weather
watches have been issued for all of our
area even over into northwest arizona
for thursday morning into friday evening
very good chance those are going to turn
into fire weather warnings as we get
closer because we are looking at
stronger winds thursday and friday 98
today those winds kind of shifting to
the northeast up to about 20 miles an
hour through the afternoon and evening
and then lighter winds wednesday then it
looks like with the help of those
stronger southwest winds we could make
it to 100 or above on thursday but
behind that front that's where it gets
cooler look at those 80s for highs on
friday mornings back into some 60s where
they belong and maybe even a little bit
cooler and then 89 saturday the weekend
looks fine but we do warm up pretty
quickly again and might even hit those
triple digits back again on monday
tuesday